[Musique]
aujourd'hui la bataille juridiquement
est pas considéré comme une personne à
part entière
en revanche
on se pose la question de savoir est ce
qu'on peut quand même considérer
juridiquement cet avatar comme le
prolongement de la personne physique qui
l'a créé ou si l inverse étant donné que
les intelligences artificielles confère
aujourd'hui une part d'autonomie à cet
avatar est ce que on doit le considérer
comme une entité distincte de la
personne qui l'a créé
[Musique]
les droits fondamentaux avec le droit de
propriété le droit à l'égalité par
exemple avec l'interdiction des
discriminations
tous ces sujets là ont vocation
aujourd'hui à pouvoir s'appliquer dans
le métavers s'est néanmoins là où il ya
un vrai sujet c'est des vrais zones
grises c'est sûr par exemple les données
personnelles ou aujourd'hui il ya des
nouvelles données qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas nécessairement appréhendé par
le fameux rgpp le règlement général de
protection des données qui couvrent
toute l'europe par exemple les
expressions faciales on sait
qu'aujourd'hui mes talents ses
enseignements facebook a déposé des
brevets pour justement
détenir un droit de propriété sur ces
expressions pour en faire commerce et
ont disposé
en droit pénal français aujourd'hui le
harcèlement sexuel tout comme le viol
ont vocation à ne s'appliquer que
lorsque ces infractions sont commises
sur une personne on en revient presque à
notre question initiale de qu'est ce
qu'un avatar est ce qu'on peut
considérer la bataille comme une
personne on sait qu'aujourd'hui donc
juridiquement ce n'est pas le cas et
donc qui a effectivement des zones
grises pour appréhender genre de
comportement dans le métavers 6